das Photon beklagt schon seit
längerem eine Lücke zwischen dem
Deutschen Kabarett und der amerikanischen
Ständer Comedy lassen Sie mich hier kurz
zu Beginn vielleicht ganz kurz versuchen
diese Lücke ein klein wenig zu schließen
neulich las ich auf einer toilettenwand den
Spruch dumm [__] gut seitdem plagt mich
das brennende Verlangen nach einer Affäre mit
Andreas kalwitz willkommen zum Genre Kabarett
heute abend dass ich in der letzten Zeit
danke schön dass ich in der letzten Zeit
doch erstaunlich vielfältig präsentiert nicht
wahr warum auch nicht warum sollte der Graben
der durch die Gesellschaft geht nicht auch
seine Spuren im Kabarett hinterlassen und das
macht letztlich das Satire Sortiment ja auch
eigentlich nur ein bisschen breiter sie haben
die Wahl da gibt es das Kabarett der Vermögenden
weißen Männer die 16-jährige klimaaktivistinnen
angreifen und die ihnen vorwerfen der Greta
sie würde mit ihren Plänen die das Leben von
Milliarden Menschen aufs Spiel setzen und
deren Tod billigend in Kauf nehmen und dann
Zitat die da nur wo finden wir dann vier oder
fünf Milliarden freiwillige zum Ableben wer
sucht die aus macht Greta das selbst ich
traue ihr das zu den Blick dafür hat sie
und wer auf diese Art und Weise Minderjährige
klimaaktivistinnen assoziativ an die Rampe nach
Aussicht stellt um dort leben zu selektieren
wird in diesem Land als Rebell gefeiert wenn
wir Menschen dazu auffordern sich in der
Öffentlichkeit von Rechtspopulismus klar zu
distanzieren dann finde ich sollten wir das im
Kabarett auch machen können sie haben die Wahl
oder Sie wählen das andere Kabarett nicht wahr den
Markenartikel Kabarett mit erhobenem Mittelfinger
das ja auch heillosen naiv irgendwie die Ursachen
vermissstände bei den Verursachern sucht das
ändert natürlich nichts ich weiß dass meine
Kollegen wissen das auch wenn politisches Kabarett
irgendetwas beim Zuschauer verändern würde dann
würde Wolfgang Schäuble doch schon seit Jahren von
seinem Pfleger Jens Spahn in der Seniorenresidenz
zum fröhlichen Sonnenuntergang zur Wassergymnastik
gerollt werden und ich könnte hier ganz entspannt
stehen und Witze über Österreicher machen
gerne wird ja an diese Form der Satire
der Vorwurf erhoben dass da ja eh nur
Leute reingehen um einen Kabarettisten etwas
sagen zu hören was die Leute sich eh selbst
die ganze Zeit sagen und wenn der dann das
sagt dann lehnen sich die Leute zurück und
denken sich nur endlich sagt's mal jemand noch
nicht gehört habe ich übrigens den Vorwurf an
Helene Fischer sie würde nur zu Menschen singen
die auch die Musik von Helene Fischer mögen ich
persönlich sage ehrlich habe mir noch nie
Gedanken darüber gemacht wer zu mir kommt
bin schon froh wenn einer kommt und ich bin
auch froh wenn nicht allzu viele CDU und
Wähler hier sind ich erwarte schon ein Minimum
an politischem Interesse bei meinen Zuschauern
auch mehrere grünen Wähler würden mich überfordern
nicht verfüge nicht über die Fantasie und mich an
Menschen zu wenden die in Robert Habeck mehr
sehen als den durchschnittlichen Vertreter der
nächsten Politiker Generation der seine Kritik
an der Regierung gerade so fest formuliert dass
sie Medien Vertreter unverbrauchte frische
attestieren aber gerade so wachsweich dass
sein eigenes Vorankommen in Berliner Politik
Betrieb nicht gefährdet wird und so toll kühn
wird ja wohl keiner sein dass er heute hierher
gekommen ist und von mir Ausführungen über die
SPD erwartet über die SPD das lacht doch schon
seit einiger Zeit in den Bereichen Nekrophilie
ich persönlich möchte ohnehin möglichst wenig
von Olaf Scholz sehen ich fürchte immer schon
diesen Augenblick an dem er versucht zu lächeln
dieser bizarre Moment in dem man im klar wird dass
die Evolution für diesen Vorgang nicht genug
Haut vorgesehen hat und wenn sich dann sein
wachsfarbenes Organ über die schädelstrukturspannt
wie damals als Fantomas sich die Maske
gut ich sehe einigen Gesichtern an dass
sie sich sagen das ist aber nun wirklich
kein Inhalt recht haben sie aber ich sage Ihnen
auch dass dieser Tiere sich mit der SPD wieder
inhaltlich beschäftigt daran muss die Partei
noch ein paar Jahre arbeiten und ich werde mich
auch heute Abend nicht mit dem Generalsekretär
dieser Partei beschäftigen mit Lars klingenbeil
sehen sie nichts gegen ein geistiges Duell
aber ich schieße nicht auf unbewaffnete
sagen Sie mal finden Sie das eigentlich nicht ein
bisschen unhöflich sich ihren alle Öffentlichkeit
über jemanden lustig zu machen der wie Lars
klingen bei seinen Sprachfehler was für ein
Sprachfehler denn naja er spricht und ich
befürchte ich habe auch ein bisschen das
Gefühl dafür verloren was Menschen in diesem
Land wirklich bewegt vor zwei Jahren haben
160.000 Menschen eine Petition unterzeichnet die
Horst Seehofer zum Rücktritt aufgefordert hat